hundreds of mourners have paid their
respects at a mass funeral in east
london in the eastern cape province
twenty-one young people died under
mysterious circumstances at a bar during
a party after school exams
south african president sula maposa was
among the dignitaries in attendance
there is blame
and blame must be laid at the feet of
those
who are making money
of the dreams and the lives of young
people of south africa
by breaking the law
and selling
alcohol to underage children
no one has been arrested but the liquor
board has laid criminal charges against
the owner of the bar for selling alcohol
to underage customers he's denied any
wrongdoing
while investigations continue there's
speculation that carbon monoxide
poisoning may be the cause of death more
than a dozen people who were at the
venue that night were treated for
vomiting back pain and headaches
police have yet to release an official
report leaving grieving families with
more questions than answers familiar
johannesburg's south africa
david monyer is a political commentator
and associate professor of political
science at the university of
johannesburg he says what happened
highlights the country's broken society
i think it is to do with a society that
is
uh went through an apartheid era and
you have
certain norms and values that
parents do not have control
young families
others are just children led
feminists and others just misbehaving of
young
children who are getting into uh alcohol
um
and this happens mainly in societies uh
in sections where unemployment is high
and unfortunately in this
case uh the results was just uh
21
young lives uh perish in this manner
it's a set a sad day in south africa
today as they bury these 21
children but i think
after handling this i said
incident there is a need to look into a
national level
beefing up laws which the president is
promising as well as to have major
campaigns to ensure that we as parents
do indeed parent
our kids in a right way